بالنسبة لكثير من الناس ، هذا ليس مهمًا ولكن
بالنسبة لي ،
لكن هذا يعني أنك كنت في الواقع
يمكنك رؤية بياض العيون
التي يطلقون النار
عليها وأنت تطلق النار
على شيء أراه ولن أفعله
أبدًا  نسيت
أنني أصيبت في نفس الحالة التي
قتلت فيها الآلة نفسها ملازمي الذي
كان على بعد حوالي 10 أقدام من يساري في اليوم
السابق لتلك المعركة ، لقد فقدت أعز أصدقائي
ولم أتحدث عنها لمدة 40 عامًا
[موسيقى]
في خمسة أيام  كانوا عند
نهر ألبا والتقى فوجي بالروس ،
كان لدينا العديد من الألمان الذين
استسلموا لنا لأنهم لم
يرغبوا في أن يتم القبض عليهم من قبل
القوات السوفيتية
[موسيقى
] لم يكن من الممكن أن ينتصر الروس في الحرب
بدوننا
وكان بإمكاننا  لم ننتصر في الحرب
بدون الروس ، كان لدينا اتفاق متبادل على
أنه كان علينا القيام بذلك معًا ،
وآمل أن أرى العرض مهمًا
بالنسبة لي
لأنه لم يبق الكثير من الناس ،
وربما لا يوجد الكثير من الأشخاص
في الاتحاد السوفيتي  تُركت
لتتذكر مدى سوء الأمر الذي كان
يعاني منه العديد من الأشخاص  الناس في الولايات المتحدة
لا يعرفون الكثير عما حدث في
حرب أن الناس في فرنسا أو إنجلترا
أو روسيا أو السوفييت لديهم
اهتمام أكبر بذلك لأنها أثرت
عليهم أكثر فقد
فقدوا أجدادهم أو
آبائهم وأتحدث معهم  الناس لأنني أريد
أن أتأكد من أنهم يتذكرون ما حدث
ولم يحدث مرة أخرى
[موسيقى]
نعم ، كان من الرائع تلقي رسائل
من الأطفال على وجه الخصوص ، بالتأكيد
أنا كبير في السن ولكن يمكنني الرد على بعض هذه
الرسائل التي سأكون عليها  سعيد لجعلهم متأكدين
اكتب لي